c'est pas qu'ils ont fait le test de
miss france on va faire ça pendant cinq
minutes giuly et au restaurant à la fin
celui qui reste il aura un magnifique
cadeau ok je vais le relooker moi même
pendant le suivant cadeau sa passion bah
ça sera pour le présent un cauchemar ben
bravo sac à dos août à arrêter ça va
hein c'est d'être une icône maddin vous
dites mode maladresse à accomplir et non
pas parce que j'ai déjà comblé penser je
voudrais qu'on me disait que j'étais une
code voilà et les gens le savent
regarder sur twitter hashtag économe
voilà bon allez je pose des question
s'était posée à miss france est d'accord
regardez la passe le test de culture
générale
c'est les seuls mots qui passent un test
de culture générale devant la plage ces
châteaux de sable les questions de
culture générale tu t'es déjà vu à
l'école c'est comme ça faire d'emprunt
aller qui a prononcé qu'à prononcer
l'appel du 18 juin 1940 à la radio sur
les ondes de la bbc
c'est d'accord ça m'a parlé s'est levé
le doigt
ben le pas dans le cul
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas vrai c'est mon ami on est en
dessous de ce week-end et on sait pas
lâcher a dit qu il faudra rendre sa
barracuda et on était comme sa ligne
ouais je vous dis la vérité
il est moins d'état de notre super show
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
très peu trop de soleil quoi il a jeté
pas d'idée belles choses je crois que
c'est bourré thébaux leca prononcé
l'appel du direct avec cette musique à
prononcer avec l'appel l'appel du 18
juin et pas charles de gaulle par
charles doumba oui cognos eric naulleau
moi je vais d'ailleurs benameur cédé à
tello là c'est le club de lecture
allez hop était le titre de cette
peinture à l'huile sur toile réalisée
par théodore géricault que j'en passe le
radeau la mezzo la méduse
attention la méduse attention amis du
cerf à cet été 1 sur le languedoc refusé
de laisser la sphère emile zola atypique
et sur la rente j'accuse badr fc oui
mais c'est bon réhausser les questions
de 3 ans id ouais ouais c'est pas des
questions pour le prix goncourt
le petit
à toi ça mais n'y a pas de limite ce
soir ça fait longtemps vous n'êtes pas
venus là on n'est que dans la d'arkham
ces minutes tu va pas rigoler
franchement vous prenez vos cours vos
claquer vos clics accueillant c'est bon
t'es le prince a reçu un hommage
national au mois de septembre
abbassi quel français bat toi le petit
un hommage national s'est perdu allez on
va vers du grand chirac et toi pour toi
cette question ouais mais bon quel homme
politique à ce moment la chanteuse
moi j'étais dans les chanteurs je
pensais à kenji girac mais c'est pas bon
kelly quel est le plus long fleuve de
france à céret c'est pas le rhône c'est
la loire oui combat dragon travaux la
loi et ça va tiens toi c'était facile
jusqu'à présent je suis sûr jour ils
eurent moi quoi une dure cherchera une
question miss france bébé d'accord c'est
vraiment le questionner lui étaient
posées aux me seront jouées le chanteur
devenu cette année le premier
milliardaire du rap et le mari de
beyoncé jazy
c'est jozi le maintien pour vous les
bourrel ça le 6 juin de cette année de
quel événement historique avons-nous
célébrer des soldats actuellement
débarquement bien sûr et ouais tiens toi
depuis 1er janvier 2016 quand même
région la france qu'on s'appelle non en
france 18dans 18-18 l'orbité de chang'e
tient pas c'est un plat c'était pas
s'affronter la question du temps mais
c'est la plus imprécise quoi aurais tu
il revendique non noté le beh histoire
l'aviation la question la plus imprécise
y en a eu qu'un pas vous disiez la
polémique est tu crois qu'amy francs
j'ai pris le j'ai pris deux qui les
habitue les matrices les intitulés
précisé croyais vraiment que tu fais
scheer changé bon alors l'échec sur
quelle île napoléon bonaparte et a fini
sa vie sainte hélène j'adore la poire
belle hélène
quel est le prénom de la célèbre
suédoise de saison qui milite contre le
réchauffement climatique round greta
garbo que bon
on attendait le prénom c'est très bien
c'est bien attention avec naulleau non
qu'elles vivent français s'est déroulé
le g7 du 24 au 26 août
oui c'est dans ma région biarritz
biarritz bonne réponse à venir tu
chantes balance tout quoi ainsi en gêne
bravo quelle nation à remporter la coupe
du monde de rugby 2019 l'afrique du sud
vient jouer
vous vous êtes éliminé toi le petit et
sont les célèbres parents du jeune archi
né à londres le 6 mai 2009 beau s'ils
n'ont pas tout le temps passe et meghan
markle est arrivé harry reid
blake mais le français rosbif
confinement et mais il a été éliminé
non non non un casting de super héros
sorti en 2019 clôt un cycle de 22 films
dans la saga marvel en lui son le rallye
c'est ça les questions il va dire sous
le soleil
alors non mais ça doit être c'est quoi
les avengers mais c'est bon ça game
exact oui oui c'est vrai je te donne le
point également d'accord mais c'est bon
pour éliminer toi attention car au
niveau parisien a pour surnom la dame de
fer
franchement cécile fin quelle chanteuse
française d'origine malienne interprète
le titre pukki au aya nakamura
bravo tiens qui a repris 0 qui a
représenté la france à l'eurovision 2010
9 2019
c'était c'était bill and will al hassani
oui bravo vous avez gagné vous avez
gagné vous avez gagné
[Applaudissements]